what's up guys and welcome back to
another video so in today's video we
will go through the bat plot live
library of Python and this is a super
useful library for all things data
visualization in Python so the video
will start off with going through the
matplotlib basics so as you see on the
screen will be creating like line graphs
such as the one you see here you'll
learn how to format these lines in
different ways you'll be able to add a
title you'll be able to add labels to
your x and y-axes format your tick marks
properly add a legend etc so all the
kind of basic matplotlib things you want
to know then we'll move into other types
of graphs such as bar charts and we'll
finish this video off with going through
all sorts of like real world examples
where you can kind of combine your data
science skills that you might have using
like pandas library and if you haven't
learned anything about the pandas
library I recommend you watch my video
on that so with that the kind of real
world examples will do stuff such as
like plot the USA versus Canada gas
prices off of data that we have a little
link to in a CSV we'll do some histogram
stuff we'll do some pie chart stuff and
we will do some box and whiskers chart
stuff I can't get through every type of
graph in this one video but if there's
certain things that I didn't cover and
you really want me to cover it let me
know in the comments that would be super
duper yeah that's all I got to start
this video let's just jump into it all
right let's start out by loading in the
libraries that we need for this tutorial
so we're an import and map plot live as
our dot pie plot as peel of T we're
gonna import numpy as NP and we're gonna
for the later examples import pandas as
PD and run that and so if you have all
these us like already installed you
won't get any errors if you do get these
get an error when you're trying to run
them onto these you find need to install
it so you can either do a pip install
matplotlib pip install numpy pip install
pandas or you could install a Python
distribution that already has these
packages such as anaconda I'll link to
how to do this
the description okay so now we have our
libraries loaded let's now build our
basic graph so I just think it's kind of
the hardest part about anything with
Python in general is starting with that
blank blank space so what I recommend
for matplotlib is always start at the
documentation so I have a link for this
in the description but here is the home
page of the matplotlib pipe lot
documentation and what I recommend is
like whenever we're trying to do
something new just do a ctrl F and like
look for it so if we look for plot here
that's like we're just trying to get a
line graph on the on the screen box
plots not only one we don't want it been
plot okay this looks good plot y versus
X as lines or markers so this is what
we'll start off by doing as you can see
right here and the examples it gives
gives plot X comma y so that's the
command will F the run to make this work
and just to know what x and y are if we
go down to parameters they tell us that
commonly these parameters are 1d arrays
so we know we need to pass in 1d array
to the plot function so if we do plot 1
2 3 that's gonna be our x + 2 4 6 will
be our Y I can't type and run that plot
is not defined so we imported pipe lot
as plot so when we run this function we
actually have to do P love T dot plot
and then this is our X and the second
array is our Y so let's see what happens
there yay we got a graph and to clean
this up a little bit I recommend moving
our variables into removing our arrays
into variables so X is 1 2 3 and Y is 2
4 6 and we can change now this to X Y
and one thing that's annoying with the
matplotlib if you're doing this in
Jupiter notebook by default is you have
this annoying little line here so you
want to get rid of that you can just
actually call plot dot show and that's
the correct way to actually show this
graph okay now that we have just a line
on the screen let's start adding a
little bit more to our graph so to do
this let's go back to our documentation
and go back to just the pie plot so I
think this is a good spot to start
because you always can kind of just ctrl
F and find something you're looking for
so let's say we wanted to add a title to
our graph if I type in title it points
me right to a couple different places
that I probably want to look at and
right here is what we're looking for so
set a title for the axes click that and
this tells me all sorts of stuff about
how I call this so it looks like I use
do pie plot title so I can do plot title
and let's just do our first graph and
run that as you can see our title is now
there and same thing for a lot of the
different parameters so going back to
the documentation if I want an X level
on a while label I just type in right I
guess I knew that but let's just say Y
label nothing comes up Y or just even
label C label label a contour plot
that's none of us the fig labels no pie
no title no X label Y label let's how we
get there so you can keep doing this and
really easily find what you're looking
for I think it's a good place to go if
you kind of just if you forget things
because I always forget things in that
plot lid okay so adding a label to x and
y plot an X label
x-axes and I guess I'm getting really
enthusiastic because we keep adding
exclamation points to all of my stuff
y-axes yay
see what happens yeah and I want to just
get rid of these recommendations I don't
need them okay so now we have a graph
and we have a title and we have y axis x
axis in a real graph we would label
these properly but for the sake of this
example we're just kind of getting a
feel for how we add these alright so now
that we have our title and labels one
thing we might want to do to them is
resize them so if we look at the the
documentation for title one thing you'll
notice is that you can use you can pass
in this font dictionary and it gives you
a little bit of details about the font
dictionary here but basically there's
all sorts of options that we can do and
like play around with our font so let's
say I wanted to change the font of our
title a new font dict equals and I can
pass in a font name and let's say I my
good old trusty reliable comic sans ms
will be our new font and if you look at
that we got a nice new font on a graph
and if you can't see it well then in
that case I'll change the font size to
be something like 20 now you should
definitely be able to tell that I've
changed the font type and in the
description I listed I put a link to all
the known matplotlib fonts that you can
use and if you look through the
documentation you kind of find some
different options you can do with this
and you can also do the same thing with
the labels I could do like font dict
equals let's say I wanted to make this
font
arielle and that obviously might be the
default but if I did it like Comic Sans
as well
you can tell that x-axis now has changed
but I wouldn't just leave that this be
for now okay so we did labels all right
so that one thing that's bothering me is
the tick marks I want to let's say I
just want to do integer numbers and I'm
gonna add a couple more values to our
graph so I'm gonna go to five I'm gonna
start at zero and Y would go from Y is
always going to be two times X so it's
gonna look like that oh I would
magically did it for us
at that case I don't want it to
magically do it for us okay let's say we
went to four and we wanted just the
integer values we didn't want any
decimal value so how do we change our
ticks so we can do that by doing plot X
ticks and our X ticks will do 0 0 1 2 3
and I also just found remember this
command by using the documentation and
our wide ticks will be I have a 0 to 10
every 2 so it was 0 2 4 6 oh my gosh 10
as you can see that now we have the tick
marks working properly and maybe I
wanted to add 4 as well so now we
labeled our ticks differently and one
thing that's cool to know is that the
graph will automatically resize based on
how we set this so if I set one tick to
a thousand well now our graph kind of
looks like not too good but it's nice
that you can easily do that 4 is better
but and you can do the same thing with y
I'd say when do they make the last one
100 as you can see it changes up the
sizing of the graph one thing that's
also cool though is find it even if I
didn't even lis space these out if I did
like 7 he
and then 7.5 as you can see it properly
puts those at the right spot in the
graph I'll leave it like this I'll leave
it a little bit weird but yeah that
looks good to me okay so we have our
first graph let's add a legend and make
this line a little bit more exciting
color wise so if we wanted to add a
legend we can do and I'm gonna actually
kind of like showing how the
documentation is helpful if I looked up
legend
Figg legends that might be work just
this legend place a legend on the axes
like by looking up legend I I've figured
out that the call is just legend and it
gives me some examples so I always like
to refer to this documentation okay so
PLT legend and what happens when I do
that no handles with labels fans put in
legends so it's complaining because we
don't have anything to label what it's
saying is how do we label this line and
the way we do that is by passing in a
label to our plot function so in this
case our X&Y we plotted X to be or Y to
be 2 times X so I'm going to call the
label here 2x and as you can see we get
2x right there
okay let's say now that we wanted to
change up the color of this line maybe
make it thicker do some other things to
it if we go to plot
whereas plot we'll see all sorts of
properties that we can do and plot so
what I'm seeing right here is you can
pass in all these different parameters
to our plot and it probably lists off
what we can put maybe not it's not super
specific but if you look hard enough you
can see all these properties that you
can pass into the plot function so one
thing we could plot pass in is color so
if I passed in color equals red will
work and it will know well I think the
common color so if I did yellow if I did
like yellow which is not a color it's
gonna yell at me might even work with y
yeah cool and we also can pass in
hexadecimal colors so I could do like a
B a B a B and we got like a grayish
color you get this is helpful because
you can pick use like a color picker
tool and pick pretty much any color you
want here but we'll stay with red for no
the other parameters I could pass into
that let's see what else we had I could
do I think line size equals let's say 12
oh that is not a print parameter not
remembered either go back to Maya
documentation size marker size maybe
that's a marker size oh I also see you
line width here so line width equals 2
ohmygosh line with equals 12 makes this
big line maybe two it's a bit bigger
than I think what we had we can also do
we can label a marker so let's say I
wanted to add dots into this as you can
see you can't really see it too too well
but maybe I made the marker size a
little bit bigger and I'm just kind of
passing this in so you could kind of see
what you can do
oh that didn't work let's say 10 yeah as
you can see nicely big dots on our graph
I can also do marker edge color there's
all sorts of properties I'm just like
continually passing these in but now you
see a different type of dot and whatnot
so this is pretty cool that we can have
all this customization it sometimes
takes a little while to get what we want
but it's usually it just is nice to have
this power and one final thing I'll pass
in is line style
so there's all sorts of line styles we
can pass it and you can read all into
the different ways you can do this in
the documentation one thing that's
pretty cool
is that instead of listing all of these
keyword arguments sometimes we just want
to make a different type of line quickly
so there's actually a shorthand that you
can use to kind of do pretty much the
same thing
so I comment this out real quick we have
no graph what you can do is there's a
shorthand notation that allows you to
kind of have a pretty good amount of
customization quickly so the shorthand
notation is color marker line style I
guess so if we go and copy this line
from above let's say we just passed in
this now what we can do is before we add
our label we can pass in the shorthand
notation so I can do color will say read
it I think just accepts letters you can
look into the documentation see exactly
what it does
marker will do a dot and then line will
do a dash so watch what happens when I
do this gives us a nice line with dots
in it if I do two dashes gives us a
dotted line if I do like a different
type of marker you can pass in like a
carat like that gives us a line with
carrots in it it's kind of cool that you
can do this shorthand notation and get
different types of lines very easily
just to follow up on the whole shorthand
notation pulling in the docs for the
plot function it shows all the different
markers you can use and the different
line Styles supported and the different
colors supported so check out the plot
documentation to see all that all right
let's move on to our next thing and that
will be I guess let's just add another
line
quick to our graph so we have our first
line let's add line number two and this
one will make a little bit more
interesting and the thing is like here
we had a very straightforward like you
have X any other Y but this is not
always easy to do especially if you have
like a function like sign where you want
to plot it at like a bunch of values but
those values are all like you know crazy
decimals so I'm going to show you how
you can handle something like that so
this is where we use numpy so nobody
call this x2 I'm going to say that x2
equals NP a range 0 to 4 and we'll go by
0.5 as our tick so if I print out x2
real quick you see that this gives us a
numpy array with zero zero point 5 1 1.5
to 2 point 5 3 to 3.5 I'll actually make
it good a 4 point 5 so it goes at the
same spot as our other graph because
this is a exclusive here so we have that
so that's gonna be our XS and so what I
can do here is I can go ahead and plot
that and I'm going to plot the square
function for it so I'm gonna pass in x2
and then instead of passing in a why I'm
just gonna do x2 and I'm gonna do
squared what happens here so now you see
we get x2 squared
it goes a little bit higher than our
original axis was set so I'm going to
change up the ticks or maybe I'll just
kind of comment this out and see what
happens for a tick marks yeah I'm fine
with just leaving the default that it
gave us looks good to me
and now we have two blue colors so let's
make this a different color maybe you
make it red we want to give it a label
as well so I'm going to do red and I'm
going to say the label is equal to x
squared
and one thing that's cool is that it
automatically moved this legend to the
top left because the positioning was
better now that this goes up to the top
right okay so we have two two lines up
there and from the original image I
showed there's some stuff that's still
different one thing that's kind of cool
that you could do is let's say you had a
graph that stopped but you wanted to
kind of show the projection of it not in
the future so what I did to show that
type of a phenomenon is I did like X to
take the first four values here it'll
plot that what did I do
oh shoot first four so what I want I
think that will work take the first
floor and plot that and then for the
last values so from let's say five or
three all right let's make this a little
bigger like this six or five bear with
me here from four onward we'll make it a
dash line and I had a little bit of
overlap because I think it'll look
better you'll see in a sec four - make
this still the same function but this
time we're gonna make it a dashed line
so there you see and I'm going to
actually make this a little bit
different
there you see like maybe something ended
here and then you make it - the rest of
the way you could do something like that
using the format I just showed all right
what else do we have probably clean this
code up a little bit
another thing that I showed in the
original graph that I showed when I was
a introducing this video was a resize so
let's say we wanted to resize our graph
well we should do that by near the top
of our graph so I'm going to go ahead
and do resize your graph I'm going to go
ahead and do plot dot figure pass in fix
size and we're going to say let's make
the dimensions 5 by 3 it's kind of an
arbitrary 5 by 3 that will give you kind
of the ratio of your X to Y or Y but to
specify how many pixels it is you're
gonna want to pass in a second parameter
which is dpi which basically is pixels
per inch so I recommend using a value of
around 300 here if you do smaller values
you'll have more pixelated graphs so if
you can afford having a bigger image
having a bigger dpi is often nice so in
this case we have pixels per inch of 300
so this is going to actually be 5 inches
by 3 inches so that Tolle pixels will be
1500 by 900 here in this graph so now
it's much much bigger maybe that's a
little bit too big I didn't I'm going to
be blocking this graph so I'm gonna make
it a little bit smaller but you get the
idea then here so we'll make it like two
by 1.5 that's not a good dimensions now
though
[Music]
I mean just play around with this the
the biggest issue I have right now is
the graph looks so big because I have my
screen super high resolution or super
the view is like very up close because I
want to make sure you guys can see my
code but yeah this would be at 1500 by
900 graph I'm gonna just for the sake of
the graph decrease the DPI and make it
more reasonable that the issue you can't
really tell from this image but if you
really zoom into the graph and maybe if
you like printed the graph out it would
look maybe a little bit pixelated with a
dpi of 100 so probably try to keep this
value higher if possible and then
another thing you want to do is you'll
want to save your graph so to say we can
do plot dot savefig and when you do say
buy graph dot PNG and one thing that's
nice too is like I pass in the DPI
parameter here as well so let's say when
I actually see if my graph wanted to be
bigger but for the sake of being able to
show you guys in a smaller format I
wanted the 100 above I can still go
ahead and save it with 300 and then kind
of solves both of my problems and so
this then my graph dot PNG will save in
the current directory that this MATLAB
matplotlib tutorial is in it was yeah
well saving that current the current
director whatever fought whatever
directory of your file not pot Lib
tutorial is in this graph will also save
there when we run this cool now we have
that saved all right let me clean this
up a little bit
and just to note the reason I did this
is because this is exclusive the six
here so when I do five onwards it picks
up this actually ends at five because it
doesn't include six so it actually
covers everything here
all right now that we've shown line
graphs a bit let's go and do quickly do
bar charts and after bar charts I think
we're going to just end this video short
and I'll do the real-world examples in a
video that I'll post next week I just
think this video might get a bit too
long if I include everything in just one
video so all right so I want to do bar
chart
okay so bar charts are pretty
straightforward as well
let's say we had some labels a a B and C
and some values that say 1 4 & 2
well if we wanted to do a bar chart we
can just do plot dot bar of labels comma
values at Friday they're wrong its
values comma labels and we get not what
I was looking for okay let's see it is
actually labels first then values ABC
cool so that was pretty straightforward
and I can do the plot dot show we're
going to do all the adding of titles and
whatnot the same way as before in the
line graph example let's skip over that
for now
it could also resize it let's say so I
could do plot figure fig size equals
it's a six by four it's gonna use
whatever the default dpi is and then one
thing that it's cool that you can do
with bar charts is you could add
different patterns to these so to do
that and you can you can really play
around with the documentation do all
sorts of different things I do some kind
of following the graphs that I was
showing the inner intro
video so I wanted to just show kind of
what different hatch values look like so
I can make first one have I'm gonna say
bars equal plug up ours there you go now
I do bars zero set hatch that's gonna
give me the lines that you see down here
I can do the same thing with the second
value let's make this circles and you
can find out the hatch values and the
documentation as well let's do the third
value we'll do stars so now you get kind
of a cool little bar chart I can also
add a legend to this very easily and
this will tell me right away we have a B
and C but I mean their label right here
some legends probably not necessary in
this case all right let's see what else
does I want to do with this and then if
you wanted to make this a little bit
neater if you had like many more I might
get tiring to do this so you could do
something like patterns equals /o and
star and you could do instead of this
notation you could do ya for a bar and
bars bar dot set hatch guess we want an
index as well
we'll just do actually patterns dot pop
first item off so this would get us our
right one for each one should yeah look
at that if I didn't pop regularly I
think it would take off the last so this
will be stars instead of yep look at
that yeah so basically what it did is it
just popped off the first item for the
first bar popped up the second item for
the second bar and then popped off the
final item for the third bar as you can
see there
in this video we're going to build off
of what we didn't in the last video
which was kind of an introductory video
to Matt pot Lib library of Python so in
this video specifically we're going to
be kind of doing some real world type
examples so basically combining our
knowledge of the pandas library with the
matplotlib library to create all sorts
of different plots based on CSV style
data so we'll start out with a
spreadsheet that all provided my github
page link in the description to gas
prices over time for different countries
so with that data sheet will build
charts such as the one you see here then
the second data set that I provided is a
list of all the game the video game
FIFA's player stats so if you're not
familiar with that and basically all of
the soccer players or I guess if you're
an international viewer watching this
all the football players in the game
FIFA provided all their like overall
stats in the game and will build grab
all sorts of charts off of that so we'll
do like histogram stuff with players
overall rating in FIFA some pie chart
stuff more pie chart stuff a little bit
more complex and then finally some box
and whisker chart stuff based off the
FIFA data and if we have time maybe one
or two more graphs before we begin
couple quick I guess announcements first
is if you've enjoyed any of my videos
it'd mean a lot to me if you can
subscribe and also along the same lines
if you don't mind also following my
Instagram and Twitter
basically the more followers I get on
all my social media platforms the more
content the more serious that I'll take
this and the more content that I'll
produce all right we'll start this video
off the same way we started the last
video make sure you load up the
necessary libraries I'll be editing with
Jupiter notebook using Python 3 but you
can
using other IDs and text editors as well
so we're importing these three libraries
matplotlib numpy and pandas then the
next step will be to download the data
that I provided for this so to do that
go to my github which is in the
description and we want to download two
different files so that files the first
file we want to download is this gas
prices so the easiest way to think to
download this is go to the raw and then
just do save as you can and you want to
save it wherever you have your code so
my code these Jupiter notebooks for me
are in this map pot Lib tutorial
directory so I would save this value
here as you see I already saved it and
then for the the other data file the
FIFA dataset we're gonna want to do the
same thing so go back to the main file
in the github click on FIFA data this
one you can't even preview but just
click view raw right click and save as
you want to save it as a CSV file so a
comma separated values file and you'll
also want to save this in the same
directory that you have the file that
you're writing your code in okay so now
that we've saved the data let's start
playing around with it and if you
remember from my pandas video the way
that we can look at a CSV file with
pandas is we can do something like will
call this CS or will our data gasps
equals PD read CSV then we need to type
in the name of the file we want to read
we've saved it as gas prices dot CSV and
we should be luron that no issues and we
saved this file in the same directory
that this map pot the editorial file is
in so that's why this worked if you save
this file in a different directory you
can specify where you save it so if you
save it in like a data folder you would
specify it so it's with this type of
syntax okay yes so now what we can do is
look what to see what's in our
this data file so if I just do gas and
this works in Jupiter notebook but in
another if you're just using like
sublime text you'd have to like print
gas or you could just be looking at the
actual CSV file and like excel so gasps
we have year and then we have all these
different countries and their price and
US dollars per gallon for gas that year
so the way I look at this we're gonna
have year as our x input so ah stop
texting me so based on the year each
country has a different gas price so the
way we can access that is we can do
something like PLT dot plot and so our X
data is going to be gas a year our Y
data is gonna be let's say we start with
USA so USA is all caps here so I have to
follow that same syntax when I'm
accessing that gas that USA and then I
can do a plot dot show and I think
already there we'll have a basic graph
up and running so as you can see yep
this is the basic graph for our data and
we could also add another country we can
do plot plot let's add Canada year gas
Canada I think yeah as you can see now
we have two different graphs and as you
can see from this it's easy to see more
easily than just reading the CSV that oh
okay
every year gas and Canada is
consistently higher than in the USA but
we have some problems with this graph so
like one thing that I see that's an
issue is all these years like I don't
know I think it just makes more sense to
be looking at the exact year especially
since this data wasn't like broken up by
month so like I don't like the x axis
labels we have no title we have no real
good indicator of
these values mean up here here on the
y-axis so we need to start fixing some
things up and quickly to know if you
have like a multi-word name this format
of dot year probably won't work so you
could also do bracket notation to access
that field as you see it still works so
if we had something with two names and I
don't remember let me look at the data
again see if any countries have that
South Korea for example like we would
have to use this syntax so I'll actually
plot South Korea's gas in this list
their gas prices so plot plot gas year
gas South Korea wouldn't work maybe
actually it would work with the
underlines I'm not sure yeah
South Korea's having issues so what we
can do is south space Korea now we have
three lines and Wow
yeah the gas in South Korea is even more
expensive okay it's just kind of
bothering me mixing these different ways
to do this so I'm going to change this
back to here change this back to year
and only leave the South Korea like that
because it has to be like that okay so
now we have some plots let's make this
graph overall better though so to start
let's add a title so to add a title if
you remember from my last video and feel
free to review that again we can just
use peel detail I can label this like
gas prices over time and US dollars and
so it still doesn't make too much sense
because you see all these lines but you
don't know what they represent I mean we
only know that what they represent
because we see the code here but we
should add a legend and so to add a
legend we're not to first give these
plots labels because if I don't give
these labels watch what happens plot dot
legend
oh wow it worked I was not actually
expecting that to work try to think why
that is that it worked
whatever it worked without needing to
add the labels specifically so that's
kind of nice for us I guess due to the
fact that we're reading this in and we
kind of from a nice CSV that already has
headers it probably worked but in our
last video you had to add label so I
could actually change the label if I
wanted to if I wanted this to just say
United States see that change it like
that so you can add this optional label
parameter if things aren't working for
you properly but for us it just kind of
magically did the trick okay so this is
looking already a little bit better I
might make the graph a little bit bigger
let's do that I can do plot dot figure
big size equals say 8 by 5 so now that's
a nicer sizing it's more easy to see
everything the legend is a more
reasonable size and comparison of
everything in there so that's bit better
what else can we do to this well we
don't have any labels for axes so we
should definitely do that also I really
don't like that these tick marks are not
exact years so I think the next thing
I'm going to do is change up the ticks
so x ticks what we can pass in is just
the year here so now it will have a tick
for every year that we have data for Wow
and that looks absolutely fantastic yeah
obviously issues with this - squished
together so what can work well is if I
print out gas that year you see we have
part of a panda's data frame but we have
over one of these years if we remember
you know some good old list
comprehension
this comprehension the list iterating
syntax maybe that will be the word but
you know when you want to get certain
items like the first five items on a
list you go zero to five or you could
even just do five what we want to do is
iterate you know maybe take every three
years so what we could do to do that is
we don't care where we start it so we're
gonna start at the beginning we want to
end at the end but we want to skip every
three years so now we get all the years
in a we get every third year which will
probably be better when we graph it down
here so I'm going to do that now so
guess year tick tick three colon colon
three cool that looks pretty good all
right
I also kind of would like to have exact
values here kind of show exactly where
we're plotting the points so to do that
if you remember the shorthand notation
from the last video we can do stuff like
will make us a blue dot - so blue is the
color and we want a dot - we want dot
markers and a dash a straight line
basically we're saying cool so now we
have every third year but we have points
for every time we actually have a data
point so that looks good we do the same
thing for the other ones red - and
what's cool - is you see that the legend
changes as we do that
South Korea let's say green dot - cool I
like the look of this still we need to
do some more modifications let's add
labels to our X and y-axis so X label
will be year that's pretty
self-explanatory then the Y label
we'll be US dollars cool so now you can
see you know okay and year 2008 South
Korea paid approximately $6 per gallon
of gas we're all translating all these
values to US dollars while Canada paid
about four dollars and the u.s. played
about three dollars so that looks pretty
good to me and we can easily add some
more countries here so I could like add
Australia for example and we'll make
them ah I don't know what color to use I
don't know that anymore I got a yellow
shirt it might be ugly color yeah it's
not too bad
but yeah and there we have Australia
looks like they're missing maybe a data
value for 1990 I'm not positive but yeah
we can easily do this for all of our
different graphs and we could even do
something like let's comment this out
temporarily let me do something like for
country in gas let's see what happens at
that print country yeah cool this is
giving us all the different countries we
don't want year so I'm going to say in
gas one onwards now we have Oh No
close close close okay I'm gonna be a
little bit hacky here if country is not
equal to Year print country now we get
all of the countries and so what we
could do with this now is you know
that's probable need of a way to do this
then if country is not equal to year but
I'm just trying to show you how like we
can do this very quick and efficient
like dude gas that year and then country
and we'll let it self select the colors
but we could if we wanted to specify
marker equals dot and think the line
style will be fine already
oh no unrecognized character and oh okay
can't just do country we need to do gas
country look at that now we've got all
the different all the different
countries in our graph and you could
move there's ways within matplotlib to
like move the legend outside of the
graph I'm not going to go into that
right now but another I guess comment
that I have is whenever you're doing
anything with matplotlib or anything
with python in general is like quickly
do a google search like how to move
legend outside of matplotlib graph and
you'll find probably on Stack Overflow
within the first three searches someone
that had the same problem as you and
found an answer to it so I always
recommend doing that but this is kind of
cool that we were able to quickly graph
all these different lines for all the
different countries and if you wanted to
you could like create a list like
countries to look at maybe not the best
name and you could choose exactly which
ones you wanted to include and then you
would do if not equals a year and we
actually you could just do if country in
countries to look at you'll do this real
quick
if country in countries to look at so
you see this is another way we can graph
specific things cool cool cool all right
I'm gonna comment this out temporarily
and just leave I'll leave it I'll push
it to the github when we're done with
this video and it will uncon with this
again cool and yeah you can play around
with this style you can use the
shorthand notation or you can use the
long hand notation that we kind of used
here but you also can reference the
first video I posted on matplotlib to
really play around with your line graph
styles
alright we're pretty much known of this
graph but a lot of a couple final things
before I move on to the FIFA data and
doing some other graphs so the first
thing is changing up the font size I
mentioned this in the previous map plot
lib video I did but I thought I was
worth mentioning again so we can add a
font stick to our title and actually we
can add this to any text based label so
you also add it to the X label ony label
and we can do all sorts of different
tweaks to our font I put a list in the
description to all the different fonts
you can use here if you wanted to change
up the actual font type but I'm going to
keep the font type the same I'm going to
change the font weight I'm gonna make it
bold so you see it now it's not bold but
if I do this watch what happens now it's
bold and let's say I also wanted to
change the font size I would say font
size and let's say it's size 22 so now
we have a larger font maybe 18 is a
better value so we can do that you can
do that for any of your your labels
another thing we might want to do is
in the when I showed this graph
originally I also had of the year 2011
we don't have values for 2011 but maybe
you wanted to allow for the ability of
that showing up and maybe project where
they're going you could do Plus you take
your ticks and plus 2011 ah that did not
work so this is a litter this is a data
frame so you can't just directly add
2011 so we need to make it a list still
didn't work and the problem is the data
frame is kind of weird when you add just
a direct list so you can do dot to list
and now do this now you see 2011 is
there and then if you wanted to actually
save this graph remember we can do plot
dot save fig we can give it a name so
gas price figure sure and remember when
we're saving if you change the DPI
you'll get a higher resolution image so
300 is a good value this is gonna make a
pretty big image it's going to make a
300 times eight which is 24 hundred by
1500 image but so really you can play
around with this video but the higher
the resolution or higher dpi the higher
resolution image you're going to get so
whoo I want to say this is a PNG so if I
went into that folder that I had as you
can see where did it go refresh oh I
don't know where I'm saving this just
propose figure where are you alright
sorry I tipped us in wrong savefig and
you always just you can refresh and look
at the documentation I'm gonna have
government yeah I got an error here I
should have noticed that before but yeah
say fig one word do that now if I go to
the folder that I have these files in we
got gas price figure and if I bring that
in you see the figure there saves nicely
as a PNG all right let's move on to the
FIFA data now that we're done with the
gas price
stuff let's move on to using our FIFA
data so we're gonna first gonna have to
load it in so in if you didn't save the
FIFA data maybe skipped around this
video it's on my github page and the
link to that is in the description and
you want to save it in the same
directory of the file that you're using
to produce these graphs Lou I'm mixing
my words load FIFA data ok so to do that
we'll just call FIFA equals PD not read
CSV and I believe we called this FIFA
data dot CSV and that's just check make
sure it's loaded in properly cool and
this is actually shoot it shouldn't have
loaded at all ok it's still a preview
but you could do something if you only
wanted to see like the first 5 rows you
can do FIFA dot head five all right so
so you can get a feel for what's in this
data you got like the name of the player
and you should probably recognize some
of these guys names Leo Messi Ronaldo
Neymar all very good players I think
it's right now sorted probably by their
overall but yet all the stats from the
game FIFA for these guys and I think it
just provides a good set of data to work
from and also I took this data from a
cat goal challenge I'm gonna link to the
original source of the data as well down
the description ok so what can we do
with this so to start off let's do some
histogram stuff
okay so what I think is cool first thing
to do is plot the overall skill level
here that you see on the right just
figure out in the game like how many
people have above a 90 how many people
have between an 80 and 90 etc so what we
can do to do that is we have our data
already loaded I don't have to reload a
10 but I can go ahead and do let's see
plot and the way that I remember these
commands is like I showed in the last
video you can kind of use the PI plot
documentation as your kind of your
starting point and then if you're
looking to try to do a histogram lookup
histogram within that documentation the
link to the documentation is in the
description and you'll find the command
hist so what I can pass into history to
set we're going to pass in the overall
skill level as my input and let's see
what happened going to do that and then
I'll do a plot Dutch show so I don't get
all this random stuff okay that looks
pretty good it's already starting to get
there what would probably be more
helpful is if this kind of these tick
marks were centered for each bin that we
have and I'll do that in a sec all right
we're gonna set the bins every 10
overall skill level points so like the
highest you would be and the FIFA game
is 100 the lowest you could be as a zero
so we'll do our bins at intervals of 10
up to from zero to a hundred so the
first bin that we have will be all
players that have a skill level between
0 and 10 and it's counting that number
50 60 70 80 90 and then finally 100 cool
so oh I didn't do anything yet now we
can set the bins parameter of the
the histogram to our bins now we got a
nice a little bit nicer of a graph now
the next thing I'm going to do is set
our X ticks to be the bins as well so
now it's nicely labeled each interval
corresponds exactly with what we have
here but it looks like we have some
unnecessary data so it looks like
there's very little players over here so
maybe I'll limit this start at 40 and go
up to 100 and what's kind of crazy is
you know the players that are over a 90
are really a rarity because you can't
even see that bar from the 90 to 100
range there so let's do a little bit
you're not a title the same way as
before got a while a ball so I'll do a
wide labor real quick number of players
and the X label would be the skill level
and we could have a title that would be
like distribution of player skills in in
FIFA
I think it's FIFA 2018 might be 2019 not
positive so that's a cool little
visualization and you can get more into
details like to actually see that there
are some values there you could do you
change up your white X to be let's say 0
to 100 okay that didn't work
yeah yes it's kind of tough with all of
these players but if we did move it from
like 80 to 100 you see that yeah there
are actually players that are above a 90
is just very very few compared to the
amount of players in the game another
thing you could potentially do is maybe
break it up use the data and only look
at the stats of players and certain
teams and then you wouldn't get all the
noise I guess in the lower skill levels
that I put all the people in here one
little modification we can make to this
is let's say we wanted to change the
color of our bar I could set this you
know I could set it to red usually like
that or I could set it to a hexadecimal
value very easily and what I recommend
whatever you want a certain color what
you can do is just like do a google
search for a color picker as you see
here I can just move this bar around and
no matter what color I want so let's say
I want this greenish color I copy that
hex code hide this paste in the hex code
now I get that green color I kind of
like the bluish color so I'm gonna go
with that but yeah you can play around
and get any color you want with that pot
lid all right let's do pie chart snacks
and just to start off I kind of
mentioned this the histograms but to
like figure out how to do a pie chart I
usually just start at this documentation
lookup pie plot a pie chart is right
there and then with this page I can kind
of get all the details of what I can
pass in and what are the parameters that
I can play around with yeah a lot of
good stuff here okay so the wedge sizes
are
so that's what we're gonna input here so
what does that look like okay so I want
to just output some of our data again
and what I think we're gonna do for this
first chart is one of the components of
this I guess we can't see it here but if
you open up the full I can't see all of
it if you opened up the full file within
like Excel you'd see that one of the
parameters we can have is preferred foot
so if I look up that you see that left
or right
it's what whether you play left you're
ready in soccer so what I'm thinking
would be interesting to do a pie chart
on is the percentage of people that play
with their left foot versus their right
foot so how would we do something like
that well we can count the number of
people that play with our left foot by
doing the following and this plays into
the stuff that I taught in the that we
went through in the pandas video but we
can use the dot lok to kind of like look
up the data set and kind of filter the
data set by specific condition in this
case for left we want to the condition
to be apologize one sec when the
condition to be if the preferred foot
column is equal to left then we want
only the data that this condition holds
and because we're going to need to pass
this into a pie chart what we'll want to
do is get the count of that I believe
this count gives us an array I can
probably check so let's see what is the
left yeah it's like an array here so if
we do count 0 we'll actually get a
number
as you can see 4211 players prefer their
left foot and so we can do the same
thing with right FIFA
FIFA bird foot equals equals right get
the count of that and then because this
returns a data frame we have to take the
we'll just take the first element which
it will be a number and let's see how
much you like right okay so considerably
more people preference their right foot
than they left that makes sense okay so
now how do I do the pie chart we can do
plot pie this is from the documentation
and I guess I kind of jumped ahead but
you might like think maybe I can just go
ahead and do FIFA preferred I can't even
spell of course I like foot and like
figure that it might just plot the pie
chart while doing that but it it gets
messed up when you don't pass it numbers
so what we need to do is passing a list
of numbers so what we can do is left
comma right so now we have two values
and I'll make a part pie chart out of
these values look at that cool and I'll
do plot dot show one thing I'm noticing
is these colors are really ugly and also
nothing is labeled right now so going
back to the documentation you can see
labels is list sequence of strings
providing the labels for each wedge we
need to pass in that we can also change
up the colors with a writ list as well
so let's do that so labels will do
equals left and right and we'll pass
those into our pie chart do labels
equals labels cool so now at least we
have like relative percentages I mean we
don't know the exact percentages but you
have an idea just based off the graph if
we added in colors we can change this
ugly orange from
there she could pass in two colors let's
say like we're gonna just use some
hexadecimal values we're just typing in
these in randomly and now I have to pass
some colors here cool now that looks
alright maybe you'd want a little bit
more contrast but it doesn't really
matter too too much you can be the judge
of that
I do Auto percentage this should forget
exactly how to format this I'll have to
check so others percentage format
percent
so we can use percent notation here so
we can do % point 2f and basically
they'll just fill in whatever value is
for the percentage with 0.2 two decimals
of floats and I guess I screwed that up
probably also be a string cool so now it
actually gives us our percentages so
twenty three point one nine percent of
the people in the FIFA game prefer their
left foot over their right foot and if
you want to actually see percent on that
it's a little bit weird and just do
percent percent basically if you just
did percent I think it would bug out
because it's expecting specific notation
basically by doing two percentage points
in this notation it knows you actually
do want that percentage sign all right
and then we can add a label the title as
we've done in the past preference foot
preference of FIFA players
cool and there's a basic pie chart I'm
trying to think of there's other things
I should add to this well we'll get into
a little bit more complicated stuff and
the next pie chart that we'll build so
this is a pretty simple pie chart let's
make another pie chart
all right pie chart number two so in
this one what we're gonna do is look at
the breakdown of the weights of the FIFA
players and we'll plot it as a pie chart
so I mean okay let's look at what the
weights look like so I'm going to print
out wait here okay so we have a list of
all these weights what we can see is
that there and note that they're in
pounds they're not into kilograms as
many of you guys might expect and pounds
but you could initial step you could do
to this pie chart would be to convert
all these values to kilograms that'd be
a fun little exercise but okay we have
all these pounds and one thing I
immediately noticed is if we're trying
to count ranges of these pounds it's
gonna be tough with this pounds string
attached is there anything else I notice
here no it's mostly just that but okay
so basically what I want to do is reset
the weight category to not include these
pounds and just be the number so this is
going to be a string right now and we
just want this converted to an integer
so let's try to do that okay so we're
going to reset the weight column and
what we're gonna want to do is strip off
so X here I'm going to do X for X in
FIFA eight so X in this case is going to
be a string so we can do strip lbs so
that will give us just this part of the
string
perhaps in FIFA wait let's see if that
works
float object has no attribute strip and
I mixed I was expecting that all these
would be strings start to start with but
because they're not what we can add is
an if statement within our list
comprehension I'm going to just say if
type x equals equals strain I'm guessing
maybe there's a couple of empty values
or something so we're just gonna kind of
ignore those and then else X so if type
x equals equals string we're gonna do
this else just leave it as is that's
what we're saying here let's see if this
works
now we print out FIFA eight cool cool
and I'm gonna take the first value real
quick and notice it's still a string so
what we're actually going to want to do
to this line is surround it with the int
block which will convert it to an end
now if I look at this FIFA dot we 0 we
get it as a integer value I don't know
why it's giving a decimal here but
should be an actual value and you notice
because the point 0 we know that it
probably is being read as a value ok so
now we have these values set right so
let's start counting things so we're
gonna start with light players and we'll
say light players I have a weight under
this is kind of arbitrary of a rest say
that they have a weight under 125 pounds
and then we're gonna count that just
like we did in the last example then the
next condition we'll do is I guess
medium light players that would be above
125 greater than or equal to 125 then we
need an and condition the end condition
and the way we're going to format this
with our Panda
notation is like that and this is
probably review a bit if you did watch
watch through the pandas video that I
did and FIFA 8 is less than 150 let's
say so now we're getting only the rows
that have both of these conditions true
we're going to count that 0 keep doing
this I'll price peed this up when I edit
the video I'm going to just get three
more categories
all right cool so we have five different
weight categories and I can like print
these out I don't know invalid syntax
what do they do
Oh didn't end up 369 heavy people medium
heavy let's see if this is a valid
number 4000 so yeah it makes sense that
there's more between 170 and 200 then
there are people over 200 in the league
it's kind of tough to be a soccer player
or 200 pounds okay so let's now plot
this so what we want to plot will be our
weights and I'll make this an array
light weights
medium medium medium heavy and heavy our
labels yeah can't type today
all right so plot dot pie weights let's
see what this looks like cool it looks
pretty good but it has no labels right
now now I'm gonna do a plot touch show
so we need to add some labels so under
125 it's the first one 125 to 150 is the
second 150 to 175 is the third and 175
to 200 its fourth and finally over
200 is the last and it will pass these
in with our pipe chart okay cool so now
we have all these labels one thing I
don't like and this is a good little
thing to know is you couldn't I don't
like the default color scheme and
instead of passing in all five of my own
colors one thing you can actually do is
I don't know what I just typed in I
didn't mean to do that I'm getting ahead
of myself
is there's a plot style and so instead
of the default which is currently set
aside as you can see it stays the same
when I do that we're going to use the
style of ggplot and I'll link a list of
these different styles in the
description so I personally like this
color scheme a lot more when I change
the style of our plot okay so that's
pretty good
we can also add the auto percentage as
we did with the last example so
percentage point 2f percentage is a
percentage percentage cool but things
are a little bit ugly in this case the
things are squished together so how can
we resolve this problem and really if
you go into the documentation you'll see
there's a lot of these weird names and
you might not know what everyone means
but if you kind of look up like if you
did a google search like pie chart
Python numbers getting in the way of
each other you probably find some
different solutions so one solution we
could go ahead and try would be setting
the percentage distance so the
percentage distance is the percentage
distance from the center of the graph so
if I did centage equals percentage
distance equals zero you'd see
everything's right there so instead of
that we'll do like 0.8 so this comes
zero to one is within the chart and you
could even do if you want it to like 1.5
and that would be values outside the
truck but 0.8 was a good value that I
thought okay so this baby makes it a
little bit better these numbers right
here that I'm highlighting aren't as
squished but they're still not great so
the other thing we can actually do is
use this explode property and what
explode does it breaks the graph apart a
bit and so let's see what that does so
we need a list that's as big as our yeah
this could be a list it can be too full
I'm going to say that was a tuple that's
what I did when I was playing around
with this doesn't shouldn't matter
0e 0.4 I'm gonna these are the values I
want to get to but we'll start with
doing them all point one and I'll reason
to why I got to the values that I got -
okay so explode equals explode so this
is gonna split the graph apart so it's
not actually touching so you see that so
that's cool but really we don't need
everything exploded we really just need
these values that are very close
together to explode a bit so what we can
do to that is all right so we want under
125 and over 200 to be exploded a bit
more as you can see those correspond to
our labels here we don't really need 150
to 175 to explode it off because that's
pretty set we don't really need 175 to
200 explode
so what does this look like now and
we'll have this explode a little bit
this is this 12.6 1% cool and I think
that this looks decently good now you
can more easily see the different
slivers and
I guess it's tough because this sliver
is so small the under one under 125 but
think that you can more easily read this
then you could win all of them or
compact together and as in the other
examples we can also add a title so
weight distribution of FIFA players and
we would want to spay that this is in
pounds cool and also as you notice
because I changed the style the header
actually changed too so that's one thing
to be a little bit careful with with the
Styles but sometimes they can be very
helpful all right because this video is
getting kind of long we're gonna end it
with one more graph but if there's other
types of graphs that I didn't cover in
this video or my previous video that you
want to see let me know in the comments
so we're gonna do a box and whiskers
chart and really the question we're
trying to ask here is how can we compare
teams like the
how good two different teams are in our
set so looking back at our FIFA chart
let's print that out so you can see that
all these players have a club so we're
trying to compare the relative strengths
of different clubs and so there I
thought that a good way to do that would
be this to use this box and whiskers
chart which shows shows your highest
player or it shows your highest score if
you have a box and whiskers chart it
will show like the max it'll show the
mean and then I'll show a box around
where the middle 50% of scores or values
were I think that's a good way to
compare a team where you can kind of see
okay where's the best player at where's
their worst player at if everyone got
injured and then the the middle box is
kind of like the core of the team like
how good are they so I think it's a good
way to potentially compare two different
teams maybe you can disagree with me and
maybe there's a different way you would
recommend but well that's what we're
going to do in this example so to start
let's uh take a couple teams and count
their their overall scores for that club
so we'll start with I was a good team to
start with go up top we'll start with FC
Barcelona so we're gonna do Barcelona
equals FIFA Lok so we're going to filter
out all the rows that have people from
Barcelona so we can do FIFA club equals
equals FC Barcelona yeah cool and let's
see and then we want when we do our
averaging we're gonna want to take their
overall score so we can just filter by
that too so now if we print out
Barcelona because we're comparing the
overall scores I think that's the most
useful metric you see we just have a
list of all the players on Barstow
their relative their overall performance
in FIFA cool then we could do that with
another team let's say we do Real Madrid
FIFA Club echoes equals Real Madrid and
when you want to take their overall
values as well cool so this is two
different values we can see Madrid here
and all those values okay so now let's
plot a box and whiskers chart for that
so to do that we do lot dot fox plot we
pass in Barcelona and it will pass in
Madrid so these are the all the values
for Barcelona and all the values for
Madrid and correspondent so what we see
here so it will know this function will
know that it needs to make a boxplot off
of that so what does that look like okay
one thing I noticed too this is also a
residual effect of changing the style in
one cell style is still changed I'm
going to change the style of here back
to our default style so default style
looks like this graph doesn't really
tell us too much right now but we'll get
it to look a little better in a second
and I want to do plot dot show so all
this stuff is not there okay cool so
this is a comparison of the two teams
relatively you can see they're pretty
dang even I'd say Barcelona has a slight
advantage it seems like it's boxes a
little bit higher than Real Madrid's but
and also their best player is ranked
better than really Madrid's best player
but it's kind of annoying when it's just
as one and two down here so let's add
our labels
so it's a list FC Barcelona and Real
Madrid and then we can go into our box
plot it has a labels property and you
can double check the documentation to
see this labels label is cool so now we
have our two different box plots and so
these two teams with this comparison I
would just say that they look pretty
similarly matched like they could go
ahead to head probably be a pretty good
game where you really see kind of the
coolness of visualizing this data with a
box and plot and like comparing two
teams is when you take a team that's not
as strong so my local team here in
Boston is the New England Revolution
they're an MLS soccer organization so I
also pass in some scores for them and
they're short tend names the revs so I'm
gonna just call them that instead of
typing out the whole New England
Revolution every time and yeah I wonder
which I say the England Revolution and
we're going to take their overall and
you could look at all the different
teams in the datasheet and get like a
certain team that you wanted to look at
pretty easy yeah you just have to be
careful that you type in everything
properly and apparently I did something
wrong
oh okay yeah we also have passing the
ribs here cool so now we have three
teams and you can see that the New
England Revolution is significantly
worse than Real Madrid or Barcelona
which is what we were wanting to show
let's add a title here and we'll add
some style to this chart as well
professional soccer team comparison and
because I'm from the States I call it
soccer yeah you probably call football
but that is besides the point
FIFA over
all reading over all hitting is our
y-axis and we have our teams down here
in the x-axis that looks pretty good to
me okay what we could also change up
potentially would be our tick marks okay
or we could change the figure size maybe
it would look better if it stretched out
a bit more along the y-axis so we'll
change our figure size a bit plot dot
figure fig size equals we'll have the Y
dimension be greater than the X and as
you can see now it looks like this and
this gives us a little bit more detail
in the actual scores among the two teams
but you can still see the New England
Revolution is not as good and also this
name is kind of running into each other
so I'm gonna shorten New England
Revolution to any revolution just kind
of make it a little neater cool all
right so the final thing we're gonna do
is add a little bit of style to this
graph so it looks a little bit better
and you also if you wanted to yeah feel
free to add more teams to this and like
really see the differences between
soccer teams and FIFA but we will add
some color around the perimeters of
these boxes maybe make this line a
little thicker that represents this
represents the median the orange line
okay
so what I found to be the best way to do
this is I'm gonna save boxes as the
result of this plot and then basically
what we can do is this will store the
three different values we've plotted
here so it will help us style each
individual box a little easier so for
blocks in boxes boxes so you're getting
the box parameter from what was saved
here we want to set the color and then
this also kind of shows you
there's different ways to do these
things like I could have passed color in
here
the problem with passing color within
here is it would make everything the
same color so if you wanted like go
ahead and change a specific box I can
have a list of colors it's easier or I
guess maybe colors is not the best
example because color is probably would
allow you to pass in an array but for
certain properties it's hard to set just
one value at a time so I want to go
ahead and set the color here so now you
see that we have a different color
around our box and they're similar to
boxes here there's another parameter for
like the longest strike here and the
long strike here the whiskers of the box
and whiskers plot but I think it could
use to be a little thicker here and so
to do that we're gonna do line width
equals two and all these parameters I'm
finding from the from the documentation
okay cool so set edge color basically
and let's say we wanted to change the
fill color so change fill color and you
could as I said before like you could
iterate through these and through a list
and like each time set a different color
for each of these change filler color we
can do something like set a face color
we could all do this in one line as well
but kind of just showing different ways
you can go about things face color is
another property this actually changes
the inside of the box so what happens
when I do easier easier or easier this
is a grayish color unknown property face
color this was something that I found
super annoying when I was trying to do
this so if you're trying to set the fee
a box-and-whisker chart doesn't
recognize I can't like recognize this
property face color for whatever reason
by default see actually if I set this
patch artists property to true to allow
you to change the face color so now we
have these graphs I think that looks a
bit better we could also change up the
median line so you could do it within
this format or another way we can do it
is one of the properties of boxplot is
median props so you can also pass in
like a dictionary of median props and so
we could pass in a line width here too
so let's say we wanted this line to have
the same thickness as the outline pass
that in and there we go
a lot of the styling stuff it's really a
matter of google searching really like
you can look at the documentation find
some things from the documentation but I
find is sometimes quicker is to say how
do I change the outline color in a box
and whiskers chart Google search that
find a Stack Overflow post and then like
from there figure out I can do this type
of technique that's what works usually
well for me all right so yeah now we
have these three teams being compared
I'm going to strengthen graph a little
bit so you can see better I think this
is a kind of a cool way to visualize how
teams compare in FIFA all right I'm
gonna end the video here hopefully these
graphs were helpful hopefully it is
helpful to combine the pandas and like
the CSV is with the matplotlib library
if you found this video useful make sure
to throw it a big thumbs up and also
don't forget to subscribe because I'll
be posting a lot of videos in the near
future